well thousands of protestors have
gathered in Hong Kong for another
anti-government rally the demonstrators
are continuing their calls for
democratic reforms and against alleged
police brutality organizers described
today's March as a quote universal siege
on communists and are urging the
international community to sanction Hong
Kong's government or protests in the
territory have been ongoing for months
for more on this now we're joined by
Matias Springer who is in Hong Kong
Matias it's been quieter in Hong Kong
recently why have protesters chosen to
increase the pressure once again this
weekend it has been quieter especially
as far as violence was concerned but
protests have been going on for this
whole time although they were a bit
smaller mostly we but we've also seen a
big March just two weeks ago where again
hundreds of thousands took to the
streets the reason is of course that
protesters feel that the demands have
not been met that has the government has
not been reaching out to the opposition
with any offer of a dialogue or anything
and you've mentioned the matter motto
siege on communists the protesters also
feel energized by a series of events
there were the local district elections
in Hong Kong in November where the
pro-democracy camp has had a sweeping
victory and last week in Taiwan where
people have been watching Hong Kong very
closely the anti Beijing camp has also
won a big victory so the protestors here
clearly feel that they are part of a
bigger tendency in the region you know
that said Matias the territories chief
executive Carrie Lam said Hong Kong
could keep its one country two systems'
freedoms beyond 2047 so what would that
mean
20:47 is of course looming over this
city this is when the formal agreement
for the that founded one country two
systems' with Britain will
end carol-anne will not be in power in
2047 idea to make this prediction so it
has little practical value and what
people here are concerned with is the
state of the one country two systems one
country two systems in the eyes of
Beijing always stresses the one country
where as many Hong Kongers want to see
more guarantees for the two systems and
Beth Carrie Lam is the one person or one
of the people that have been accused of
eroding this this this firewall as
people call it between the two systems
so this is probably not going to ease
any of the tensions here in the city
all right correspondent Matthias pretty
now in Hong Kong thanks a lot